لذلك ، في حين أن معظم الأشخاص الذين
أصيبوا بفيروس كورونا يتعافون في حوالي أسبوعين ،
كان هناك هذا العدد المتزايد من
الأشخاص الذين يعانون من الألم المتكرر
والأعراض المنهكة لعدة أشهر ،
حتى أنهم طلبوا منها تحسينًا في البداية ، حيث
أشاروا إلى أنفسهم على
أنهم مسافرون طويلون قالوا إنهم كانوا  يحارب
أعراضهم منذ ما يقرب من 100 يوم من
الانضمام إلي الآن هو بول غاردنر ، إنه مصاب
بعدوى لرؤية أستاذه في
مدرسة ليفربول للطب المداري
وأثينا كراما المؤسس المشارك
لتقرير الهيئة السياسية kovat 19 وعالم
الأعصاب فقط حتى الناس  أعرف أنكم تعرفون يا
رفاق ما الذي تتحدثون عنه هنا
والأستاذ I chromia أريد أن أبدأ
معك بعد 99 يومًا من هذا وما
زلت تشعر به كيف مرحبًا جون
شكرًا لدعوتنا ، نعم ، أنا في الواقع
99 يومًا من الكيانات  وقد بدأ
بشكل أساسي وفقًا
للإرشادات العامة الكلاسيكية جدًا مع الحمى
والسعال ولكن بعد فترة وجيزة بعد
ثلاثة إلى أربعة أيام ظهرت مجموعة كبيرة من الأعراض
ضيق في التنفس  ألم في الصدر ،
تعب شديد ، ألم في الجسم ، ألم في
القلب ، ألم في القلب ، لكننا
كنا نتمنى حقًا أن نبقى
هناك إذا مرت 10 أيام ولم
ننتهي في المستشفى ، فربما تكون
بأمان وإذا مر 14 يومًا وهذا  من المحتمل أن
الأعراض ستختفي ، لكننا
شعرنا وكأنني أثبتت خطأ بعد
أسابيع بعد أسابيع ، والآن أصبح
الأمر مثيرًا للاهتمام حقًا
لديناميكيات المرض لأنه كان في الأساس
مثل لعبة الثعبان والسلالم ، لقد
كنا مثل لحظات قصيرة من الراحة
وأتمنى أن تكوني بخير
وأنا أحب نوعًا ما أشرت إلي لأن
زوجي كان يعاني أيضًا من الأعراض
وكان لديه أقل تقلبًا وأقل
تقلبًا مني ، لكننا
كنا في هذا الوقت من المرض
معًا و  لكن نعم ، مثل تسلق
السلم معتقدين أننا بخير ثم
فجأة ننتكس مرة أخرى وكان ذلك
بعد
- تقريبًا رائع أعني أنا آسف جدًا لأن
كلاكما يمر بهذا
بما في ذلك زوجك  البروفيسور غاردنر
- أنت تقول إن هذا ليس مثل أي شيء آخر
على وجه الأرض وهذا ليس ادعاءًا صغيرًا
منك لأنني أعتقد أنك مصاب بالملاريا
وحمى الضنك ، أعني أنني دخلت في الأمر
معتقدًا أنني أدير قانونًا
سيكون مجرد مرض خفيف  في الأسبوع الأول ،
مررت بحلقة
اعتقدت فيها أنني أموت في المنزل في السرير
وكان هذا في وقت
كانت فيه حكومتنا وسياسة لنا لتطوير مناعة القطيع ،
لذا لم يحدث الضربة القاضية
عندما تطورت كما فعلت عندما  أصبت بهذا
المرض ، لكن بعد هذه الحلقة التي كاد
أن أشعر فيها بأنني على وشك الموت ، كان لديّ
هذه النوبات الدورية حيث
سيأتي المرض وأضربني حول
رأسي ، كان الأمر أشبه بضربي بظهر بيسبول ،
سأعاني تمامًا من
الصداع.  لن تكون أشياء أخرى بشكل
مستقيم ، فإن جسدي كله سيتألم ، لقد
كان غريبًا حقًا والشيء الآخر
هو أنه يعبث
برأسك أو أنه فعل معي
يجعلك رطباً يربكك أنه يفسد
مزاجك وهو  هو حقا
تجربة مرعبة للغاية